not a hand out but a hand
up anyone who needs help and hope can
come catholic charities of southern
nevada keeps the door open to its food
pantry
a place traditionally low-income
families come for assistance but
ceo deacon tom roberts says the need
extends
further now we've seen some additional
clients
from the resort industry adding to the
growing demand for food during the
pandemic
it's difficult to make predictions
because things seem to change very
quickly
but we're prepared to help as many as we
can and we want to help people
families can only pick up food from
catholic charities once a month
but the boxes they're receiving weigh
about 40 pounds each and have an
assortment of items
we want to continue to provide that gap
support as long as we can
also supporting the effort is three
square the food bank not only assists
pantry partners
but continues drive through distribution
sites and monitoring the steady rise in
food insecurity
it's now prolonged that it appears to be
something that we're going to have to
deal with for some time to come we are
in a situation that is an unwritten
crisis
the las vegas rescue mission hosts a
produce giveaway on thursdays
the program may expire soon though after
helping hundreds of people weekly
you should know mid next week whether
that's going to get extended
nonprofits and others working to address
hunger in uncertain circumstances
kristen drummond 8 news now